hey guys how's it going guess who's in
my kitchen right now
yeah i'm having some flashbacks to the
last time you asked me to collab and um
i'm waiting for someone to catch on fire
well this was oh that oh that one
oh my god i was thinking the last time
we made a baking video
even longer ago that was like three four
almost like three and a half years ago i
think wait we made
call of duty ghosts cupcakes so if you
guys are call of duty fans then you know
how long
that was oh my gosh
and then on your channel we made
thanksgiving smoothies yeah so that's
what we're going to be doing
again it's like a christmas smoothie
christmas
version yeah so basically we're going
back and recreating our last collabs
that we did which was three years ago
because we're so creative we are very
creative
so today we are going to make some
cupcakes and we're going to make these
cupcakes into a christmas tree tower
i've seen so many amazing things on
pinterest like people are very talented
yeah i've always kind of wanted to do
that but first we have to make some
cupcakes and here's the thing is i want
to make a lot of cupcakes
i have a lot of cake mix oh my
but here's the problem i've had it all
for so long
that's all really cool baking cabinet
thank you thank you secret wow i'm not
even good at baking
the thing is i've had all this cake
stuff for so long that it's
all expired so anything that we make
today don't eat it
what the heck this is a rip-off you
asked me to come over to make cupcakes
and i can't even eat them
okay well uh yeah you don't want to i
mean it's not like that expired
yeah what does expired even mean it's
just flour and sugar
maybe some eggs well this one says
august of this year
and this one oh this one's actually
january of 2018 so maybe if we mix these
two together
it won't be as expired so we're going to
be making some gluten-free
cupcakes today funfetti gorgeous
thank you this thing's heavy i'm
surprised you don't have a camo one
we'll have a matte black one that's not
camo it's not
but maybe next time i don't think they
make it i guess i could probably get it
like
you know like people get their cars
wrapped right i could bring my i can
bring my mixer into west coast customs
hey guys wrap it up do you need a knife
no i'm good you sure you don't need a
knife okay
all right i'll put this well actually
maybe you can do it to the next one okay
i'm a little upset that we're using that
and not a blender i feel like
you changed the last time we collab
do you want to use a blender this is an
idressing cooking video
so you're right wow how dare you i am so
sorry i'm shaking right now okay
now we've got a blender yes but i don't
think we're gonna be able to fit two
cakes in there so we can just
whoo okay this isn't the justine i know
you're right okay
i'm too professional i've changed you
hey
wait we do need to put the liquids in
first oh shoot
it's okay i'll just pour it yeah just
put it in there why the liquid
well because it's funky i guess we can
get rid of this you've learned a lot
i've learned so much oh god
it's been a while hello okay hope i like
this new just
i'm sorry i've changed we like that all
justine
get some protein of that shell gosh i'm
having a holly jolly christmas
already yes we are not fitting two cakes
in that
did we preheat the oven no oh goodness
did i turn it off yeah woohoo good thing
this is expired
ew i dare you to drink that ooh gross no
you drink it you're gonna be eating it
soon why don't you give it a little
taste
this is expired gluten free this is kind
of weird when you see it separated like
this
oh this is a futuristic one it's touched
green
yeah drink yum protein
so how are we going to fit
this all in but you're not alone this is
gonna go
a little low it didn't go above it
didn't touch this
see look i'm so nervous
look at this is how the pros do it
and then we just mix it all in look at
this
look honestly ro is definitely she feels
a tingle
she feels like a poke she's like
something terrible is happening
it's getting real thick yeah let me um
oh my gosh
i can't believe this worked well it's
okay well
yeah you didn't think that it would fit
two cakes
i didn't think it would actually at all
so let's put this back turn it up
we're gonna we're gonna turn it off yeah
we need to jam it
okay pause oh wow this is really thick
you don't need it
expired expired these dots feel very
runny they're not
funny enough it's super thick i'm just
gonna have a look
yeah something's gonna happen let's see
let's maybe
[Music]
i'm not sure oh god this is what we're
dealing with everyone
yeah that's something i think this looks
good actually because it's gluten-free
it's a different consistency than most
normal cakes
i can't believe you fit two cakes in
there i'm actually very surprised
okay let's have a race first one to line
it up but you've already started i
haven't even opened up my thing
it's cheating okay
thank you oh gosh
yeah so watch this this is so cool i'm
so excited
once you get this little contraption a
while ago
wow that's real thick weird consistency
i don't really know what the consistency
is supposed to be so usually
a little bit more liquid but this is
it's okay
but yeah look at this oh great wow
it's a nice little poop it is like a poo
yeah so we'll fill these about i don't
know like three-fourths
sure yeah this is real thick here we go
in they go wow they look great
let's work on this frosting now yeah do
you have some green food dye
oh you better believe it
do you think this is going to be a bad
idea oh girl that's too
thin we need to go in with a heavy duty
yeah but look i got to get in real good
so it's not you're going to put in there
it's not going to move you think
try it okay it's a fickum
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah this is definitely gonna break it's
it's struggling it's in like struggle
city
i don't think it's working i think it is
look let's give it another spin
oh my god
there we go oh my gosh if you eat this
you're going to be
inside pooping black i promise you black
it's green yeah but blue dye turns black
on the inside
yes she knows from experience she knows
holy crap that is so much
oh this is fun true we can't eat this
anyway it's expired
all right well that's a look if i've
ever seen one i think our icing looks
pretty good
yeah i mean it's not as dark as i would
have liked but you know what we're not
going to be judgy of our christmas trees
this vision in my head i'm just going
like this
so funny wouldn't it be hilarious it'd
be great should we do maybe you can get
a new little like highlights and your
new do here it'll look right
okay do you have an oven mitt we don't
need those this is movie magic
wow
i also pre-made these so i'm it's called
trickery dickery doc
it's movie magic so to go with those
i've also got
we've got a lot of cupcakes more expired
cupcakes these are all expired
i was like this is perfect because i
don't know what else i'm going to use
these for i'm not sure what's going to
happen really i mean
well do you what do we what do we have
to frost with do you have a little
spatula yes sir fabulous
got a big one wow
i don't know if we need these but
let me go get some decorations let's see
what we've got i've got to have
let's see we've got let's see
i just got a butt slap that's a nice
little paddle okay so
oh that's a nice ice this is our tree
base yeah it
gets skinnier towards the top though
true so it'll be like
do you have anything on your christmas
list this year um i can tell you what's
not on my list
the iphone x it's the iphone 10 joey
it's the iphone god what you get like a
demon
can't talk bad about apple inside this
house i think this is going to be
something that people can make
you know it could become a nice fun
family tradition
that you make a yeah a christmas tree
cake hi jen wow hello jenna taylor
your hair thank you i was gonna say uh i
didn't do anything to mine
well she's about to go green i think so
her hair
yeah yeah we should stick her head in
that box
that's exactly what he tried to do
coming along nicely let me know when you
need a taste tester
oh yes yeah we do need one how do you
feel about death
good cool studied it oh wow this is
looking real good
this is looking good i'm going to start
like kind of like making it sort of
angle up a little ways
so it already kind of is right yeah but
like you know like a little more of like
a
like a like a this have you guys
decorated everything already
i really figured basically like a pile
of cupcakes
oh whoops okay wait i know i've got
something for that
what we need supports yeah just dig them
in there yeah there we go it's like a
real tree
could you take my apple watch off nick
for me please
thank you because i'm gonna get messy
thank you
looks great oh no what is happening i'm
sorry i'm sorry
i'm sorry i don't know i don't know
where do we go wrong
jeez i don't know oh no and then we'll
make it look cute
that's i think you're right because like
you don't paint a house first and put it
together
you put the house together first and
then you paint it right you know i've
just moved to using my fingers
i watch a lot of hgtv and i've learned a
lot obviously
do you have a favorite christmas song
have a holly jolly christmas that's my
favorite happy holly
jolly christmas she's been holding it in
this whole video
the best time of the year honestly just
what plays in her head all year round oh
i don't know if there'll be snow have
you ever wonder what goes on in her head
it's that
don't think about it because i'm
concerned about myself
it's looking pretty good i think it's
honestly probably one of the best things
that we've ever done i mean you know we
haven't collabed in three years and this
is what we decided to do
oh no wait i mean i guess escape the
night was like a
huge collab that's true so oh no
oh no it's okay we can we can just put
this back up here
careful you don't stab yourself with
these because it's very sharp
oh it already looks so much better it
really does
fun oh look at all those sprinkles this
looks good i'm gonna get these uh
wow that looks incredible
i mean this is something that you would
see on the food network
and they're shaking they're cancelled
yeah they are shaking in their boots
this looks good actually the sprinkles
look real cute they're shaking and
they're stockings look at this we've
also got some nice festive candles
what are the candles for um i don't know
it says that they have colorful flames
oh since my hands are sticky can you
just burn it open
that stinks thank you
[Applause]
perfect flicker flame
and now it's opened exposed i love magic
and fire and knives ew these are
ugly i know they look like they look
saggy hey justine
who had to do this to us they're so
gross
take me out of my misery please
oh we'll have her at the top she's
holding on yes in place
okay should i put all of the candles in
there maybe because we've got more
and these are our angels those are our
folding the flames yes
of love yes god i wish i had a torch
i know everything sucks without one oh
some of them are on fire
this is a big flame that's a very big
flame can't even see it
really because i freaking see it well
you don't see it
i feel like we need like a oh there we
go i see it now gorgeousness
um here oh you can see it oh my gosh
wow
do you think santa would be really
excited about oh we are making a s'more
i think we're making a bit of a s'more
happening here
i mean this is this is a perfect tree
topper i think everyone should do this
for their christmas tree
huh it's getting bigger it is getting
bigger those chains get a little closer
too yeah here
what's that sound what does that say is
is that an angel from above
it's santa claus to me i think that's
i think that's my pixel double bubble
toilet trouble
hi yeah we have an emergency we've got a
uh a fire so now what do we do still
going
she's just living her truth so do we
blow the candle
star out oh oh
wow that's that's gonna sound a lot that
is wow okay oh wow yeah i want to put
that out
put that fire out oh my gosh we've been
catching five jeez
hold on a minute christmas fires
wildfire because it's the tree it is
well guys this is
our very merry christmas tree uh that we
made out of cupcakes i'm not
sure how i feel i feel accomplished you
know i just wish that
we could eat it yeah um maybe we could
add one to my video
because we're doing the smoothie
challenge so we are so i'm gonna save
one of these
for joey's video make sure you guys go
check out joey i'll put a link in the
description where we are doing a
smoothie christmas challenge
and guess what one of us will have to
eat this so
thanks for watching thanks joey i'm so
sorry let's not
wait another three weeks let's bake more
because clearly
we create awesome bye bye
oh hello the miss sultan
[Music]
oh boy
jenna we might need your help because
i'm oh no oh god
oh no like this is going to stab through
here
oh no oh gosh oh wow there we go
all right and there's really not much on
the floor nice
ready ow
maybe we don't save one of these for
your video or do we we should
that looks good we'll save that maddie
back up honey
all right perfect wow lovely
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
you